zach pleisek is going to be on the mound
for the indians and let's see if he can
get it rolling his last start these two
matched up back in detroit last week so
he's gonna make his second straight
start against detroit and we told you he
gave up the two runs in that uh in that
ball game and both of them came in the
first inning so he's gonna try and have
that quick one two three i don't see any
reason why not he's settled in fits very
well and he feels much more comfortable
in his home ballpark
high drive center field ahmed rosario
back racing back makes the catch and
then crashes into the wall hangs on all
the way back to first goes willy castro
he's a novice in center field that was a
bit of an adventure but he hung on and
made a great adjustment at the end well
he can smile now about it but he broke
in on this ball
and you see then all of a sudden he's
got to go back so you're drift we call
that drifting drifting drifting but i'll
tell you what it's a it's all a comfort
factor out there
he made the catch good for him but
that's going to take a while
to run the routes and with two down
nomar mazzara heading to the plate
chopped in the hole
cesar hernandez with the long throw
retires mazzara to end the inning first
curveball of the night no pun intended
the tiger is forced to go with derrick
holland as their starter tonight rather
than julio tehran we'll see what kind of
answers we get to the reason for that
but
228th career start for derek holland his
first start since august 28th when he
was with the pirates a year ago at
milwaukee 0-2 to hernandez
and he chased upstairs
first out of the night for derrick
holland
and ramirez
it'll go into center field and rosario
speeding all the way to third base
well there's a break that goes in favor
of a cleveland hitter because so far
this year it has seen the breaks have
gone against many of the indians hitters
so the indians
have runners at the corners with one out
for eddie rosario
chopped to second base they'll try to
turn two there's one back to first
not in time eddie beats it out
keeps the inning alive and gives the
indians the lead well there's they had
to turn it quickly that's the toughest
way to turn that double play going 4-6-3
no he beat it out
give him the rbi and the indians will
play from in front
great hustle by eddie rosario to get
that run home and now runner first two
down for friend miel reyes
he smokes that one way out of here deep
to the bleachers friend meal reyes
second home run of the year for fran
meal it's a three
nothing
cleveland lead
well he went to the well one too many
times there staying inside fran mill
made the adjustment
and like had the count in his favor and
he did some damage
and uh pulled the hands in quickly it's
right where all the rest of the pitches
were
right there 94. that was one of his
better fastballs and friend male said ah
let me pull my hands and he's seen
enough pitches in there made the
adjustment hits the home run that'll be
his second on the year
and he rings him up
a couple of strikeouts in the inning but
cleveland with three hits and three runs
jonathan scobe leads off for detroit
strong on and miss police hack strikes
him up one away strikeout for zach
after he gave up the
lead off single there's a nice slider by
him going down the way
got the next three out and starts this
ending off with a strikeout two outside
leads it up to akeel badou boy he's this
young man been fun to watch that's an
understatement five for eleven a couple
of home runs seven rbis
through the fastball up high by badou
so playsack with a second strikeout
cruises through the second inning and
the indians lead the tigers three
nothing here's jacoby jones
and a double play ball to cesar sure is
there's one and they turn two nice job
by all concerned on that play
for four six three and hernandez
almost lead him he he led him to the bag
i watch the backhanded flip and then he
comes across
and makes the throw i don't know if he
picked it at the
first base side of it had to get out of
the way of the runner yes he did a
little bit so a 4-6-3 and that's how you
do it right there
blew it by him
third strikeout for zach please sack
another zero on the board midway through
the third three-nothing cleveland
three-nothing indians with the lead
bottom of the fifth inning and chris
this truly is one of the terrific
stories so far of 2021 michael former's
rejuvenation
swinging to miss how about that wow hard
slider right there 89.90 on the slider
he just dispatched rosario
the pitch swinging a ground ball back to
the mound followed by foamer
pick it up fire a strike to get ramirez
at first that's a really good play
because that ball trickled behind the
mound nice play
one two three fifth inning for fulmer we
head to the sixth
zac lee sack pitching a two-hit shutout
as we go to the sixth cleveland three
detroit nothing
and he got him looking good slider and
now gleesack has now retired nine in a
row
and that's his sixth strikeout friend
bill reyes is two for two tonight two
run homer in the first in the single in
the third
oh oh
deep center field way out of here
oh my
into heritage park
that thing got out of here like a bullet
train
second home run of the night for friend
male reyes and it's four nothing
cleveland
you better have a mighty big tape
measure for that puppy
four nothing indians
on a line drive home run into heritage
park and center field
zach please is dominating on the
pitcher's mound yeah is he ever looking
to go seven innings here
now the one-two offering
a swinging attacker by the mound behind
the bag and second
jimenez has it throws out bazzara two
down he is sitting here at 96 pitches in
the seventh inning with six strikeouts
no walks he kicks and delivers
and it's swung on another weak ground
ball to short jimenez will throw him out
what a job by zach please sack tonight
you know his night is done but what a
night it was he made 97 pitches tonight
he goes seven shutout innings and he
gives up three measly singles
shaw making his second appearance
we'll have the six seven eight hitters
for detroit here in the eighth inning
this one sent to deep center field get
out of here and ramos has done it again
a solo blast right where reyes hit his
the shutout is no more and ramos's third
homer of the year gets detroit on the
board let's hope that's contagious
gets a hanger out over the plate doesn't
try and pull it
smoke
443 feet
nico goodrum singles back in the third
swing of this he struck him out came
back with the exact same pitch
and it would have been ball four but
goodram chased after it
struck him out looking that was the move
we were looking for on the lead off here
all right back-to-back strikeouts now
that was pretty much the same pitch too
so he gets a second out
loop to left charging in eddie makes a
running catch
inning over
4-1 cleveland 9th in class a
trying to get a second ever major league
save the other coming two years ago
swing in a miss he struck him out one
away
i like uh the spin and the nice bite to
this slider goes straight down really no
chance
and when you have two strikes
and you throw this pitch there's a
pretty good chance you're going to get a
swing and a miss
[Applause]
just by clase glove but cesar hernandez
cleans it up two away
his 14th pitch of the inning
swing and a miss
struck him out with a back foot slider
and emmanuel klossay has his second ever
major league save
and the indians had brilliant pitching
tonight
starting with zach please
4-1
indians dominate the tigers